is
[Music]
okay so he's got to go
around taking him this
way he's got to go this way but I didn't
I didn't
[Music]
okay when you here you can t con do all
exactly what I just did to his
head and I not going to
T and go around this energy
see go around
the it's no different different if
he
um
let's and uh I'm going to fit into the
empty
space you see I fit into the empty space
see is
grip I don't want you could push through
it but I can kind of fit in it you see
so I fit in it and it's much
easier
or let's say you're my
closeth and I can turn you
over or I can move me over you see and
you're already fall
so I'm going to
go C Is Here I stay still and then I
pull and then
power I move him around and then I stay
where he's
not you see if I stay here then I got to
move him around me or he starts to go
back and I move myself myself around him
okay or I don't make him go around me at
all oh I'm going to bring him into me
but I'm not going to be
[Music]
there okay try
all right so you guys saw the filming we
used the grid behind us at the walls
okay the camera you got to go whever you
can find the angle okay so he's not
going to go past he not going to go
straight past then I
P and then I
exeler that's not what's
happen he's going to go forward true
okay so these two hands keep bringing
them forward
okay then this hand this hand starts to
turn him right and brings him into me
but I'm not going to be here I'm going
to go around his head letting his head
go by so there he is If I Stay still he
be in my head that' be normally nuget
but on this one I let his head go by you
see and his head keeps going this
way we're going to do it again and see
if you like a better Ang okay yes he's
going to keep going through with the
adians and I'm going to bring him into
me only I'm not going to be here so plop
my spine in
space when I bring him into
me I get out of the way of his head
[Music]
see
around into me out of the way of his
head now I'm on the front side he's
going backwards these two
connect and I bring him where his head's
[Music]
going don't smell your
version at no
part so you guys are okay here you're
getting out of the way but then you
smell your version
right this
way this way okay
try just a side note on on this
hand this hand is the Integrity hand
they C turn sharp on okay you don't want
to be this you can turn sharp
on S keeping them
out then it's
adhering with this hand if you take away
this hand not only can turn towards you
and you're not protecting your
radius but your adhesion if you can even
do one is at the top of the lever okay
so even even if I get some inhesion
there I'm going to have to make it go up
so that I'm not going to tilt the top
end of the lever and pin his
here so this hand is is helped not tilt
him by this hand that's giving me
my radius Integrity okay so do you feel
the left hand so this you can't push
ahead of it this is passive to the left
hand okay this is what I'm doing so I if
I start pushing you're going to
tilt okay as I don't I keep this hand
moving so you feel there's some upward
to it you see cuz I don't want you to
tilt I don't want you to tilt till I'm
you're past me then I get you to tilt
okay this time again
if you're going to cut here on the
inside he can
turn you're going to tilt him you see
before he passes you his hips haven't
passed
me so when you work this hand it's on
the
outside you see on the outside and I
don't move
it as I do the Tilt look where his head
went see this this is basic iido you you
you don't move you you don't you don't
chase things stuff will happen for you
okay so I'm not going to tilt him here
he's got to go past that you see then I
leave my hand there there it's already
there so I
shouldn't shove his head down
down I should be on the outside I
shouldn't cut his arm down and I
shouldn't go to
here and I do everything like
this because I'm not checking the arm
you see he wants to grab my testicles
I'm going to let go
okay you can't unchap the arm until he's
past you now you're in shikaku you see
his arms over here too
late okay in the way they were thinking
about the other things it's still two
dimensional okay so what do you have to
do
first yeah you have to pass me okay then
what do you have to do
what does she have to do now come
in next around you see and then she has
to come into me you see and then I have
to get out of the way so I get out of
the way by shifting my foot shifting my
weight to the other foot and that's how
you're fall
okay one you have to go past me cool has
to go around me I bring her into me I
shift my way she's
fall here go you're done on and shifting
your way to four this hand pulling you
on the circle this
hand not my
weight my weight goes out of the
way wait out of the way so you I'm not
there me and me I get out of the way
out of the way this is where you
[Music]
TR